[موسيقى]
كنت ساذجًا بما يكفي لتصديق أنه
يمكنني فعل شيء قال الناس إنه
لا يمكن القيام به ، لكن إذا كنت
تريد فعل شيء جديد فعليك أن تذهب إلى
حيث يكون الأمر مخيفًا بينما أنا
رئيس التقنيات اللونية
نصنع الحبر الذي يجعل الجبال
تتحول إلى اللون الأزرق عندما يكون الجو باردًا في المسار
كما هو الحال في
[موسيقى]
أنا مجرد شخص يذاكر كثيرا يجعل الألوان التي
تغير لونها تعرفها لجعلها
رائعة ،
أحتاج إلى شخص مثل Kira Lee hi hi '
كاري مرحبًا كاري ، أنا سعيد
بلقائك مرحبًا بك في CPI kiri Lee Jones
وقد تعاونت معًا لجلب
موهبتها الفنية وتغيير لون
عيون CT معًا وإنشاء
قطعة فنية فريدة وأنا متحمس جدًا لذلك
انظر ماذا سيحدث به
، أرسم في الغالب الجداريات ، لذلك أعتقد دائمًا
أن كل شيء عبارة عن لوحة ، لذا فإن
نوع ما أتخيله لهذا
المشروع الفني الكبير هو
مفهوم المشكال الذي
سيدخله ويخرجه  من الألوان كما لو كنت
تنظر من خلال sno  wflake وهذه
كلها الألوان ، لذا سيكون الأمر
معقدًا ، لكن قم بإنشاء
قطعة فنية غير مرئية تنبض بالحياة عندما
تجعلها باردة ، لذا فإن الفكرة ستكون
لدينا هذه المنصة هنا ذات
الخلفية المبردة لذلك
أنا أرسم
قماش ألومنيوم عملاق مبرد مع
طلاء متغير اللون يبرد ليصبح ملونًا ،
ثم عندما يكون في درجة حرارة الغرفة ، يكون
لونه أبيض لذا يبدو بشكل أساسي أنه
غير مرئي ، يبدو نوعًا من اللون الوردي
ثم يختفي على الفور.
ولست قادرًا على رؤيته ، لذلك أنا
مهتم بمعرفة ما إذا كانت جميع الألوان ترى
[الموسيقى]
تظهر جميع الألوان ، فهو يتفاعل
مع البرد بسرعة كبيرة ، مرحبًا ،
كيف حالك ، أنا رائع
هذا جميل حسنًا  لذلك دعونا
نتحقق من هذا هنا ، يا للروعة ، إنه جنون ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو أنني أكتشف القطعة أثناء
رشها ،
أريد أن يحب الجميع التواجد
أمامها وأحب أن يشعر حرفيًا
بزفير البرودة هذا مثل الاندفاع
فوقهم كما آمل  الذي - التي  عندما يرون ذلك ،
فإنهم يدركون أن شيئًا
سحريًا يحدث
[موسيقى]